Dari teleskop hingga Large Hadron Collider,
setiap alat ilmiah baru akan mengubah dan memperbarui pertanyaan-pertanyaan
yang bisa kita tanyakan sebagai ilmuwan
dan pikiran-pikiran yang penasaran.
High performance computing atau HPC
bergabung dalam daftar elite itu di tahun enam puluhan. Hari ini,
komputer quantum sedang mengetuk pintu yang sama.
Selamat datang. Nama saya adalah conducive to coffee,
dan saya adalah software engineer di IBM Quantum.
Dalam kursus ini kami bertujuan untuk mengajari para mahasiswa
dan para profesional tentang bagaimana quantum computing akan segera
bekerja bersama dengan infrastruktur HPC
untuk menghasilkan komputasi
yang lebih baik. Kamu akan belajar bagaimana komputer quantum
dan komputer klasik berkomunikasi dan bertukar data,
cara menulis program yang memanfaatkan kedua jenis perangkat keras,
dan bagaimana integrasi ini membuka aplikasi-aplikasi yang bisa kita selesaikan hari ini.
Kamu akan membangun pengalaman praktis dengan perangkat keras quantum nyata
dan kluster high performance computing klasik,
menjalankan job quantum berdampingan dengan workload HPC tradisional,
serta bisa menginterpretasi hasil dengan percaya diri,
dan mengidentifikasi tempat-tempat di mana akselerasi quantum
benar-benar bisa membantu perhitungan,
dan di mana tidak. Yang terpenting, kamu akan memahami
ke mana masa depan komputer menuju
dan peta jalan yang akan membawa kita ke sana. Kami pikir
kursus ini sangat penting
dan tepat waktu, dan kami percaya
bahwa menggabungkan teknologi-teknologi ini akan sangat penting
untuk mencapai keunggulan komputasi.
Ini bisa berdampak luas di berbagai industri,
seperti kimia yang mungkin memungkinkan
desain obat yang lebih cepat dan penelitian material,
di bidang keuangan
untuk model risiko yang lebih cerdas
dan deteksi penipuan, dalam kecerdasan buatan dan machine learning
untuk optimasi model. Dalam kursus ini,
kita akan menyelami secara mendalam sumber daya komputasi,
model pemrograman, dan algoritma quantum.
Jadi selamat datang dan bersiaplah,
banyak hal menarik untuk dibahas!